hi everyone and I'm excited to be here
to show you a connection
right here on the web we're in tableau
online right now and we're looking at
several dashboards that are connected
live to Google bigquery let's click into
one what we have here is a set of data
from Twitter that we've been collecting
with a number of different hashtags
including Big Data and other and other
hashtags it's collected by ignant
Twitter's analytics engine and we did
select on a big data set and we've got
all this data right here in the
dashboard that we can look at live with
tableau online and bigquery now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go ahead and
filter down to the last actually let's
go down to the last day or so of data
so now we're looking at the last day of
data in this data set and we've been
looking for tweets with text IOT but I'm
more interested in tweets with text
Google and so now what we've got is
we've got dashboard about when people
have been tweeting in this data set
which is all the tweets as well as about
Google which are the yellow tweets we've
got several views here this one tells us
that Google has been tweeted about about
5% of the data set here about big data
and we can see a scatterplot of all the
tweets and all the users who are using
this term now I'm gonna just click in to
the ones that are using Google
and now you can see all of these tweets
that have been posted in the last day or
so we can hover over one and look at
what the tweet was in this case they're
saying Google bigquery teams with
industry leaders see how many friends
and followers this person had and follow
all of the tweets and the social media
about the Google events that are
happening over the next couple of weeks
so what we're working against here is a
live bigquery data set let me show you a
little bit more about that if we click
into tableau online again and look at
the data sources you can see that I've
actually been working against this data
source called tweets from Gannett and
it's a live data source and if I want to
take another closer look at it I can see
that the credentials for this data set
were actually embedded right into the
data source now I could edit that and
ask users to put their own credentials
in but in this case we're going to go
ahead and keep the embedded credentials
so working with tableau online you can
actually publish bigquery as a live data
source or you can can publish workbooks
and once you've got the data source
published you can even go in and create
a new workbook so let's do that against
this Twitter data set and now you see a
drag and drop environment that tableau
has that lets you explore the data on
the left you see all the different
fields in this data set about Twitter
data and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go ahead and look at the
hashtags in this data set I'm going to
drag that out to rows and tableau is
doing a live query against Google
bigquery to try and look at all the
hashtags that are in this data set now I
want to see how many tweets there are
for each of these so I'm going to take a
number of records and in this data set
every record is a tweet I'm gonna drag
that to columns now I can sort down and
see what the biggest hashtag was and big
data is the biggest hashtag it is the
one that we were pulling on I can do a
couple of fun things like change the
color here
and I can add things like the actor
displayname to the view and what this
lets me do is it lets me break down each
one of these bars into the different
Twitterers the different people tweeting
about the hashtag so I can click in and
I can see that no sequel the hashtag the
account no sequel tweets a lot of times
with the hashtag big data that makes
sense to me
I can tooltip over another area and I
can see that there's somebody else
tweeting a lot about big data with the
display name eg Bertran weekly and an IR
gang so these are some has some accounts
you may even follow and we can also see
related hashtags here we've got cloud
and healthcare and a few other things as
well now one of the nice things you can
do here is you can go ahead and filter
based on when these when these tweets
happen so I'm going to go ahead and put
posted time into a filter here and I'm
gonna filter again live right in the
browser against a live data set of
bigquery tweets I'm gonna filter to the
last few days the last two days in fact
6 8 2 6 10 and today happens to be 610
and now you can see again the the graph
has changed we've got less data in there
and we're looking only at the tweets in
the last couple of days now with tableau
you can do a lot of different things
with your data one of the things that
you often find in data is location
information geographic information so
I'm going to go ahead and double click
on location country here you see a
little globe by it and what that is
telling me is that tableau has
identified country as a geographic field
and when I click on it I can see the
location of all the places where I have
tweets now I'm going to go back to
number of records and I'm going to go
ahead and double click on that to add it
to the view
and gonna go ahead and crank up the size
here and you can see that the United
States has been the place where I've had
the most records but I want to show you
another neat thing you can do when
you're working with data you often want
to change perspective and tableau show
me to let you do that simply by clicking
in and choosing another visualization
that might be appropriate we also have a
handy back button so if you want to undo
something you can do that you can
actually undo or redo as many steps as
you'd like but I happen to like this
view right now so I'm gonna go ahead and
save this as a new workbook and I'm
gonna call this tweets on big data in
this same project and embed the password
tableau online is a fully secure
analytics product so you can make sure
that you're enforcing the security that
you have on your data and now when I go
back into tableau online you can see
that I've got that new workbook here
tweet some big data that was updated
just a few minutes ago that's just a
taste of what you can do with tableau
online and Google bigquery when you
establish a live cloud to cloud
connection between this powerful data
source and an analytics product in the
cloud